[Música]
antigamente nova é não fui eu que
inventei essa expressão está pintado
numa parede em lisboa é um trocadilho
que do riso de inúmeras maneiras
representa muito aquilo que tenho feito
nos últimos 60 anos e que levava 80
muito tem sido esta a minha viagem de 39
anos eu gosto me apresentar como hanna
na china a encosta da serra que fica
então lá dentro dois países entre duas
culturas
che entra cidade entre duas aldeias
entre uma loja de eletrodomésticos entre
uma padaria e uma quinta é que chia com
as histórias do meu avô contava a suas
teorias dez anos nos anos 40 na
argentina e que che com o mundo que meus
pais não traziam das suas inúmeras
viagens pelo mundo fora
obviamente como bons pais ou seja o
melhor para as filhas estavam que fosse
gestora
eu gostava de ter câmera eu ir para a
tropa ea que a vai vai é o levou a
estudar arquitetura vai apaixonar de
novo nos primeiros meses apaixonar e
exerci durante mais de dez anos
tive a sorte de poder construir muito
fazer muito experimentar muito analisar
muito ganhar prêmios inclusivamente mas
percebi também que estes dez anos de
casa esta profissão mais 27 de fumaça
eram muito e muito tempo era muito tempo
esse projeto muito tempo do
licenciamento muito tempo de aprovação e
no miami tem outras coisas eu tinha
marcas de graxa
entretanto ante a organização de provas
desportivas que fazia como é normal na
minha terrinha é e tamanho e deu espaço
a 1 abrir um espaço multidisciplinar
onde para além do escritório fazendo
exposições peças de teatro é tudo e mais
alguma coisa - uma oficina de bicicletas
lá também dentro
isso é uma maior foi assim até hoje é no
entanto foi também onde nasceu aqui onde
foi cozida que eu queria mudar
radicalmente a minha vida e eu vá
uma viagem entre ainda não terminou
espero que continue por aqui
foi uma viagem que iniciou sé o 1
festival de arte urbana que o primeiro
vôo de volta a minha confiança é o que
se segue é um crime o resultado e esse
primeiro projeto foi resultado de duas
grandes paixões uma pela história que
nem pra quem não sabe que mente ligada
com que a indústria tais tempo circular
temos linhas mais 74 mais 200 fábricas
mais de oito mil pessoas a trabalhar e
depois da revolução de 64 tudo se
destruiu obviamente se transformou num
estilo estigma com que chico como o mau
cheiro que pessoa que está no lado
organizar o festival como um saque
tático somos seres que tinha que ter um
formato muito específico muitos
analistas muito bem pensado e tem os
cinco objetivos muito é muito muito
bonito despertar o interesse da
comunidade para a cultura e arte
contemporânea especial pela arte urbana
sendo que na época não existia qualquer
tipo de atividade cultural prestar
homenagem à história da corrida como
forma de descoberta da própria cidade
pra quem vive quem nos visita também
reabilitar áreas urbanas através da arte
como um ato popular democratização da
arte como envolver a comunidade em todas
as intervenções em ações e com isso
construir um roteiro é que iria gerar
ocupação e transformação
foi assim que nós começamos em 2011 com
nove eo festival o é em portugal
continental é nós começamos no centro da
cidade ao centro histórico mas olhava
nova zona completamente degradada
esquecida
nós vamos lá do melhor dos melhores
artistas que existiam em portugal e que
se inspiraram ano que era a colher para
colocarem também nas nossas paredes
vamos lá artistas quando ainda nem
sequer eram muito falado em portugal nós
não vamos lá e ele trabalhou sobre isso
a nossa cidade é um projeto muito tempo
nós também fizemos e que eu acho que
vocês também todos identificam o inside
out própria criando os primeiros também
a ser feita a nível mundial e que
permite contactar com a história é de
mais de 60 trabalhadores e empresários
da indústria têxtil
isto é digamos que o formato e
este quatro meses em que nós tivemos o
festival a acontecer que causam a casar
texto em uma semana por separado em cada
mês é permitir uma respeitada aqui
algumas coisas que somente pelas
transformações que nós estamos vendo na
mentalidade das pessoas as
transformações culturais urbanísticos em
como inclusivamente que vivem amigas que
criavam junto dos peritos é permitir um
suspeitar que a arte urbana podia ter
aqui algo que pudesse trabalhar e fiquei
com isso na cabeça
daí fui para lisboa anos onde eu tinha
meu escritório como seria desafiar as
pessoas duas vezes por ano
artistas que nada tinham a ver com arte
urbana que simplesmente queriam ser
ilustrador watters artistas plásticos
escultores é trabalhar lado a lado
durante uma semana
é daí passei para coimbra onde
trabalhamos com uma comunidade de
toxicodependentes e sem abrigo e que
tenhamos uma mensagem clara demonstrar
que coimbra tem sempre encanta não é só
na hora da despedida é a viagem
continuou volta ao interior onde
estivemos no fundão onde percebi também
que a língua não pode ser um impedimento
como dizia na taxa ou seja é nós
colocamos um artista placa que fala
certo português deve percorrer todas as
aldeias em volta do fundão para
descobrir o que são hoje 30 locais para
depois fazer é defender dela em grande
escala o momento contemplação e pausa e
termos um evento de tamanho nos
juntarmos todas as velhinhas para estar
em abordar ao mesmo tempo a fazer crochê
e encantar os cânticos específicos do
crochê que até à data não fazia a mínima
ideia que existia de kivu foi o porto é
e pediram para desenhar algo que os
vossos pessoas a descobrir os traseiros
da estação de são bento é desafiar e
vieram os operadores dos mais
reconhecidos que nós temos em portugal
para se inspirarem com as pessoas que
vivem realmente honestas nestas ruas e
conseguindo entrevistar um visual que
ainda hoje vocês encontram na na porta
da estação de são bento é prostituta os
o proprietário da casa crocodilo observe
que sempre viveu e naquelas ruas e
valores também a serem descobertos
é pelos comboios pela estação por um
documentário que foi feito aqui volto
então lisboa cascais onde pela primeira
vez trabalhar num bairro social é em que
existem muitas desigualdades e foi
interessante perceber que durante a
semana que nós tivemos com o festival
não houve tráfico de droga e as crianças
que são do de pólos opostos e de
situações opostas e econômicas brincavam
juntos pela primeira vez neste bairro da
equipe por isso é o primeiro grupo de
portugueses que foi um projeto
reconhecido internacionalmente foi
conosco também para e permitiu mostrar o
que de melhor existe já em 2013 em
portugal e também na tunísia foi uma
acção do projecto onde colocou artistas
portugueses a trabalhar em uma cultura
completamente enfrentam por exemplo o
vermelho não pode ser usada coisa que só
vemos lá daqui volta coimbra então me
pedem para desenhar um projeto artístico
que tenta apaziguar o mal estar que
existe de uma cidade com 13 e nós
transformamos isso não vai voltando
entre cidade entre difícil que nos
permite também trabalhar sobre dez
pessoas é que estavam zangados com este
difícil com a história triste difícil e
que estavam sagradas quando entre elas e
foi muito interessante perceber no final
de tudo isto é que o abraçou choros
equipamento um conforto que nós
conseguimos alcançar três dias depois
disso tudo é porque santos da casa não
fazem milagres deixa eu voltar a correr
novamente inspirar os artistas porém a
colher para voltarem é trabalhar sobre a
nossa identidade sobre as nossas tudo
aquilo que identifica toda todos os
aspectos com acidentes ficam onde nós
estamos tamanho a grandes artistas que
se diz cristã e se transforma em que se
mostre não poderia deixar de falar isso
porque está aqui ou lá dentro foi
descobrir uma das meninas que têm a
mesma paixão pelo belo e que gostaria
ter um museu em cada cidade é que o lado
estratégia que voltem às crianças com os
artistas nos permitem mostrar uma cidade
completamente diferente daquela que
tenha certeza que vocês têm é na vossa
cabeça que permita artistas que vai do
outro lado do mundo é se inspirar em por
curiosamente esta menina está aqui na
platéia é que permite artistas pensa
trabalhar é sobre a questão da imigração
sobre a questão dos conhecimentos de nós
familiar das nossas cidades que se
inspiram na fauna e na flora que
permitem criar mitos urbanos onde de
repente temos o cão do egas também na
parede onde todo o historial de todo o
patrimônio do ex-ministro também é
elogiado ontem repente temos pequenas
estatuetas que se espalham pela cidade
que nos mostra uma cidade completamente
diferente porque de repente olhamos para
cima e não sempre o mesmo nível como é
habitual onde permite contar a história
da dona florinda que a agricultora que
se vocês forem os tempos da rocha é e
ela claro é cultivar ou é casa é nossa
casa somos nós está uma mensagem pra
vocês e uma mensagem de tradições que
nós trabalhamos sempre onde quem vai em
aspecto as normas também é participando
nos vários workshops para as várias
cidades que nós vamos tentar é estão
quilinho ele esta é a parte mais
importante para mim é um deus hoje
visitas guiadas e onde o feedback
imediato que eu sei de toda a agenda
onde me permitisse avaliar essas coisas
estão a correr bem estão a correr mal
uma coisa também surge destas o vídeo
deste olhar que é sempre manente que
aquilo que levar que te turma é quem nos
acompanha sempre mais são os velhinhos
se um dia em 2012 eu decidi que em vez
de só ouvir em só verem o mesmo que ir
trabalhar e já passamos por mais de 12
da asas são mais de 500 idosos que já
trabalhamos dos 65 aos 102 anos de idade
onde aprendem o que é o grafite onde
aprendeu que garoto vai não dá pra onde
vamos criar o seu nome e no fim vamos
pra rua e pintar e engenharia dae essa
jóia em cidades anjo no brasil e é este
é o espírito e agora deixo vos com um
vídeo porque mais do que falar eu estava
consistente sem o que é o envolvimento
de uma transformação da cidade através
da arte urbana
no último fim de maio tudo o que era ter
mais do que antigamente pois eu já vi
muita sorte a
[Música]
háháhá
aaaah e trabalhar em uma empresa onde
estavam as 50 marcas e todas fazia
faziam um barulho e e aquilo era um
ruído que a gente é assim estará só
através de show e tanto ela é
[Aplausos]
basicamente a parte industrial ea partir
de agora lê da vitória as pessoas aqui é
muito fortes na indústria angolana que
move a pensar como se tivesse sido ele a
maior parte da indústria
lana
[Música]
tem que fazer e se não ficassem pode
fazer os filmes quiser provar que pode
custar mais a portagem mas já cortado
mas também fica mais nem tu ó pt a morte
do dólar
ae
[Música]
o trabalho foi sempre no ano que termina
mas como trabalhamos com letras faz
sentido para nós fazer alguma coisa que
as pessoas da platéia se identifica com
a fiel capitão nosso trabalho já as
horas e das pessoas também está na rua
são dois prédios na realidade tem duas
competições individuais pois é uma
palavra amor escrita no fundo dos olhos
podem ver dom do ponto de vista das
pessoas gostam e algumas não como vai
ocorrer se não conseguindo no poema são
criados quando dizemos às pessoas do que
que é isso
gosto que temos ea designer fica mal e
nunca será esquecida
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
willian silva
foi só de noite tudo bem
o ex treinador botou na meo
a filha
andou
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o tu és 19 mesma mensagem que quero
deixar para vocês nunca se esqueçam que
mesmo que tenham sonhos nunca deixam 19
e isto é o que é novo aqui na cidade por
banho que passei por lá e que observem
atentamente deixar só uma pequena nota
que respeita o tempo todo mas acho que
está em santos no outro dia estávamos a
trabalhar em frente esta parece que é
uma parede feita pelo diante dele é com
uma técnica muito interessante que o
pontilhismo ponto ponto durante sete
dias feito com o marcador e valem que
passou a enfrentar paredes
a ans estão ter muitos aula e não
aparece e que o prefeito fez todo o
sentido e é isso que é maravilhosa na
arte urbana que cada pessoa possa olhar
e ver uma coisa é absolutamente
diferente e que faz parte passa a fazer
parte do seu patrimônio muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]